beware literal-minded theists The
Satanic temple is coming to a city hall
near you where devotees of Beelzebub
plan to drink blood like liquids
performed fetishized faux fetus
flagellation and challenge the legality
of that beloved Ten Commandments tablet
outside your municipal courthouse The
Satanic temple is a new religious
organization that was founded in 2013
kind of as a prank but very quickly
gained a huge amount of authentic
followers theatrical stunts aside The
Satanic temple support of freedom of
expression sexual liberation and
separation of church and state would
seem to make them a libertarian a bunch
but are they a political movement a
legit religion or just a bunch of nether
worldly trolls Penny Lane is the
director of hail Satan a hilarious and
entertaining new documentary that
examines how this bizarre movement
started making its presence known in
towns and cities across America i sat
down with lane to find out what makes
the Satanic temple tick and what in the
aichi double hockey sticks their
struggles with Christians politicians
and the mainstream media says about
religion and irreligion in America today
so yeah it went from being kind of a
joke
political troll which we can talk more
about to being an authentic religion in
a very short period of time so that's
kind of a story of the film for people
who haven't seen the movie yet explain
exactly what is it what is the troll
issue and how does that troll ich miss
transform into something else so the
Satanic temple is a religious
organization for Satanists Satanism
predate the Satanic temple it's been
around for about six years as a
religious identity a small religious
identity it's been around for 60 years
so the Satanic temple seeks to gather up
all these Satanists and advocate for
their religious equality in the public
sphere and the way that they do that is
that you kind of look around the United
States of America and you find places
where the evangelical right has decided
that they want to bring religion into
the public sphere if that's prayer in
public schools or you know monuments on
public land or prayers before government
meetings the Satanic temple says great
well you've now opened the public forum
for religious expression since we can't
discriminate amongst various religious
expressions we also would like to
participate and then mayhem ensues I
think that's the kind of storyline for
each one of these actions and they've
had dozens and dozens of similar actions
around the country so that's the
trolling part right because it's an
airtight constitutional argument right
it's just it's pretty hard to argue with
yeah I mean they test the First
Amendment in several jurisdictions in
Arizona Missouri where else and and what
do they find
what do they they find that we are
extremely prejudicial about how we
enforce the First Amendment surprise you
know I mean we all know that but there's
something about the spectacle of the
Satanists coming to town that really
pushes the issue in a way that as a
lifelong atheist I can say the atheists
never seem to quite drum up the same
level of attention right like when the
atheist come and want to put their bench
next to the Ten Commandments it doesn't
quite capture the imagination the same
way as a nine and a half foot tall
you know goat headed
bathroom is surrounded by children
that's Baphomet yes right okay can you
paint a picture of what this deity
they're trying to put next to the Ten
Commandments yeah what is it it's a
great image what what is it so I'm gonna
describe it it's got a beautiful it's a
bronze monument it weighs a ton and a
half it's got a goat head with a
pentagram on its forehead
it's got Iggy Pop's chest explicitly and
it is flanked by two children who are
kind of adoringly looking up at it and
it's got sort of ambiguous gender
elements as well yeah I like that
sentimental aspect with the children
it's it's like it's for the kids you can
sit in its lap so take pictures that's
that's that's lovely and and it
outrageous people like it really people
don't regard it as a joke or as a troll
thing they really they really are
terrified by it right and it Christian
groups are the media is worried about it
especially Fox News as you love to point
out you like to poke them a little bit
not me they do it you like to show let's
not pretend you don't get a little joy
what do you back off and let people live
their lives in fact why don't you do
that
Lucian graves because religion is a
protected class so I think you should
crawl back into your hole why are we all
so gullible as my question Wow I mean
you have to realize that you know
whatever world you live in or I live and
you know something like ninety percent
of Americans like believe literally and
like you know God 90 percent I just made
that number a huge number okay so like
you know most Americans are pretty
superstitious at their core and we have
like millennia of ideas about who Satan
is and what Satan is going to do to
earth if he was to get hold of us you
know these are old ideas that are hard
to get rid of so so when you say that
you're a Satanist on the one hand there
is an element at the core of it that is
about trolling people right it's about
poking people and sort of frightening
them into a moment of shock but the
important thing with the Satanic temple
is that it doesn't stop there for them
they aren't like oh look at these dumb
people they walk away they want to then
have a long conversation
about religious pluralism in America
it's very important to say for your
viewers that the Satanic temple and
Satanism more generally does not mean
the the worship of the devil they are
atheists at their core they're not
supernaturalists their religion does not
rely upon belief in impossible things to
function their religion is about taking
kind of the best secular humanist
enlightenment values wrapping it up in
mythology art ritual community and all
the good things about religion and
throwing out the part of religion that
is about blind obedience to crazy ideas
so it's these almost universal values
and we're all Satanists at heart a lot
of people walk out of my film very
troubled because they are trying to
figure out like am i a Satanist and it's
a troubling thought for them and it's an
interesting position that I'm putting
the viewer in because I don't think most
people thought they were going to have
to justify why they're not a Satanist
today like the feeling I have when I
read reason for the first yes so well
okay so let's get into what they
actually believe specifically separation
of church and state kind of freedom of
sexuality and freedom of expression
certainly bodily autonomy bodily
autonomy are these people like
libertarians at heart kind of
libertarian II I think in general but I
don't think that they would all say that
they are or have those politics
expressly they're not a political group
there are religious organizations you do
find a range of political views within
this religious organization but when
your religious tenets are about
rebellion against Authority checking
your beliefs against our best evidence
you know sort of not discounting
scientific fact as you form your beliefs
autonomy freedom liberty yeah you
certainly see a large overlap with a
libertarian point of view yeah I don't
see them giving big opinions about
Bitcoin or banking standard yeah that's
not really the Federal Reserve yeah and
they're not because they're not right
people want to say like is this a
religion or is this a political group
and in fact it's obviously a religion
because if it wasn't a religion nothing
that I'm saying makes any sense right so
they are engaging in political activism
because in America religions engage in
political activism like
used to it like no one says is the
Catholic Church really a political group
because they engage in lobbying it's
like well no they're Catholics and
they're bringing their deeply held
beliefs to bear on their political views
you know it's the same with Satanists
and an organization that's sort of the
shadow of the shadow side of
Christianity in a sense actually appeals
to a lot of Christians you should are in
your documentary what is the appeal
there well I think for a lot of the
people that I met over the years doing
this film they were raised in a world
where the fear of Hell the fear of the
devil was used as a abusive tool to keep
them in line to keep them obedient and
to keep them from questioning grownups
basically when they were little children
and so for very very many Satanists you
know kind of embracing blasphemy
embracing the kind of destruction of the
symbols that represent that religion
that tyrannize them is extremely
liberating the day that I graduated
confirmation you know we're sitting in
church and you know we're supposed to
feel the Holy Spirit come in and I'm
just like okay so you know we look at
their religious practice some of their
ritual ritual practices and we say like
well why are they doing all these
offensive things they're just trying to
protect Catholics and you're like well
no they're doing those things privately
so it obviously has nothing to do with
what you think about it doesn't matter
and if you don't like it you're probably
not a Satanist don't worry they're not
trying to convert you but for someone
who feels this kind of last vestige of
fear that they're going to go to hell if
they say the words hail Satan or like
smash across to do those things and to
realize that lightnings not going to
strike them down is a hugely cathartic
experience and it's very liberating for
them it's kind of amazing that that
happens in adulthood for people yes yes
it does and I think I've met many people
who didn't let who didn't turn away from
the faith they were grown they were
raised in until middle age it's not an
exclusively adolescent phenomenon
although I would say most of the
Satanists that I met did come to
something like Satanism in their
rebellious youth and the ones who stick
around are the ones who are actually
really interested in the philosophy you
know not like just annoying people
another thing that really
interested me about the film is that you
see the transition in the beginning of
the film from troll culture to hey maybe
this is an actual religion maybe we're
actually starting to gain some a
following here and there's more than a
little implication that maybe this is
how Christianity started or maybe all
religions really I mean there's kind of
like a you know everyone's very annoyed
by the new religion in town aren't they
like there seem quite annoying to
everyone
it's a competitor yes it's a competitor
and they look at them and they're like
either crazy ideas how could they
believe those things you know that's no
that's no surprise it's just 20 you know
it's the 21st century so we've got it
all on YouTube clips so it's easier to
sort of see the way that that transition
occurred in front of our eyes you know
but there's really no question in my
mind at this point that when you ask not
you but when one asks you know are they
serious or are they joking the answer is
both I mean Satanism is really fun and
it's kind of about being fun like it's
sort of about you know that kind of
impish you know sort of rebellious kind
of that kind of person who's always felt
like in every group they were the one
who was like forced to say oh you know
like come on guys like why is this dogma
settling into place like there's a bunch
of people who have this feeling that
they're that kind of person I've always
felt like that kind of person who has to
kind of be the skeptic in the room so
then having a religion where all those
individual skeptics in the room get to
like be together it has been profoundly
transformative for them and also I think
for culture because they are really
having an impact in the world like it or
not I remember as a child in elementary
school I had to stand up with the rest
of the class every morning and sing god
Bless America and as even as an atheist
as a young atheist I remember thinking
this is this is this is like
uncomfortable this is this is weird and
I wish I had some sort of express way to
express my displeasure totally and I
felt the same way you know I mean saying
the Pledge of Allegiance every day in
school and really chafing at the idea of
saying under God but not having the
courage to be like a huge pain in the
ass you know like make a big scene about
it I mean
and in sort of making that choice
because most of us say we want to stand
up for what's right stand up for what we
believe in but at the end of the day
what we really want is for our friends
to like us and to get along so the
Satanists are like really walking the
walk they do not care if people like
them they know that people don't like
them and they're like whatever and I
just think I have to say I think that's
heroic
I really do the film for me was really
about elevating that kind of person to a
heroic status and then seeing how people
react to that
well they had that contrarian theatrical
element to them and I think they get off
on pissing people off right they kind of
enjoy that they absolutely do I would
say they don't do everything they do to
piss people off but they sure enjoy that
it happens along the way yeah it's icing
on the cake for sure and are they
successful where are they now is the
movement so growing is it petering out
what's going on they're really
successful there's no petering out
happening there's new chapters opening
all the time there's in fact such a
great demand for new chapters that the
National Organization had to kind of put
a freeze on it because they were like we
can't handle this paperwork we're just
people with day jobs and kids and we're
doing this nights and weekends I mean it
it is this way of looking very
impressive but it really is like rubber
bands and volunteer effort at this point
but yeah they're being really successful
in different places around the country
they are continuing to fight their
fights you know they had a really
successful holiday monument battle in
Chicago recently the Boston City Council
is being challenged in courts is the
same as the Arizona kind of City
Council's which were illegally
discriminating against Satanist in their
prayer policies the lawsuit in Arizona
about the Baphomet monument is ongoing
and the interesting thing about that one
is that you know other groups are suing
the the state of Arkansas to take down
the Ten Commandments monument that was
put on state property last year two
years ago now but the scenic temple
actually has a different remedy every
other group the ACLU the secular groups
they all want to take the commandments
down the CT neck temples remedy is put
our statue up so you know it's quite
interesting it's a different
it assumes they don't really want this
they just want to cause trouble and get
that 10 commandments down but that's not
the the outcome they're seeking in their
lawsuit and of course through productive
rights lawsuit in Missouri is continuing
as well where they're using the Hobby
Lobby precedent
to say that as Satanists they feel they
should be exempt from mandatory waiting
periods and informed consent material
that is not scientific and based on an
explicitly Christian worldview so that
continues as well so they're really
they're not stopping they're not going
to stop I think most politicians are
just kind of like if we wait this out
they'll go away and I'm telling you
they're not going away you seem to have
an affinity for these people are you a
Satanist oh it's a great question um
first I want to say I never thought I'd
be in a position in my life where I had
to explain so often why I'm not a
Satanist it's a very interesting
position to be in and one that I've put
myself into I I did not become a
Satanist in making this film I feel I'm
extremely sympathetic to their worldview
I think that their their religion is a
very good religion if I were going to
join a religion it would probably be
Satanism um but at the end of the day
it's a religious identity it's not a
t-shirt you don't just put it on and it
doesn't resonate within me and I think
it's because I was raised so completely
a religious like there was just nothing
like I didn't have any religious
education so these symbols don't do much
for me like I don't can't like you know
Satan doesn't do anything God doesn't do
anything none of these images mean
anything to me so it doesn't have the
resonance that it has fer for a real
Satanist a real Satanist would have an
emotional reaction to the image of Satan
even while they know it's not a real guy
and I just I just don't so I an
unaffiliated individualistic lonely
atheist and on that note I thank you
very much thank you this was fine yep
Penny Lane the director of a wonderful
new film called hail Satan question mark
coming out when April 17th across the
country bill 17th across the country see
it it's a it's a lot of fun it's a hoot
I'm Todd crane and for reason